this is the last and final season what
how is everyone going to cope without a
show that is so representative of
life this is us is about everyone
brilliant title too because it brings
everyone in it is a great title it's
better than the untitled dan fogelman
project which was when i auditioned for
it
um so this is us
what he landed on was that
our creator dan fogelman really wanted
to create a show where everybody could
see themselves and i remember
people asking me when did you know you
had a hit
and but i remember around episode four
or so
which was the swimming pool
and i had a cousin of mine
call me
and she's a plus-sized woman
uh she was adopted
right and she said sterling i know
you're really excited about this oj
thing you just did
because i just done that but she said
this this is us she says this show is
church
it is therapy it is healing she says i
see myself in kate and kevin and randall
like the way that this show affects my
life it's like you're saving me money on
therapy by virtue of coming into my home
every tuesday and allowing me to process
all the stuff that has happened in the
past
um i don't know what we'll do without it
i'm sure
something else will come along that is
lovely
um
i'm gonna miss it we're we're gonna miss
telling the story of the pearson family
i and i know i've talked talk to your
producers about this or not the good
thing that i feel about the show is that
fogelman always wanted to do six seasons
so he had a beginning middle and end
that he wanted to like see this thing
through it and so we're not gonna have
anything that like goes on in perpetuity
and hopefully we'll finish stronger
i hesitate to say this because i love
the show but we will finish stronger
than game of thrones all right so i came
across the article where you talked
about sticking the landing and how you
went to dan fogelman and said we
have to stick this landing
how are you feeling about it right now
i'm feeling really good i feel like it's
going to be awesome
[Applause]
i'm picturing like a 10
stick
like all the judges attend
and that perfect landing because i'm so
glad that you aspire to that it is
important
and that you have your eye on the prize
with that is so money and i'm just so
excited to see it um okay when we come
back sterling k brown is going to bear
it all this is us secrets and more don't
go anywhere
[Music]